اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 10
فلسطينيين خلال عمليه دعم شملت مدن وقرى
فلسطينيه عده في الضفه الغربيه فجر وصبح
اليوم
والخليل والقدس ورام الله ونابلس ودهمت
منازل عده
م بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال
ان العمليه التي نفذها الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مدينه جنين هي استمرار
لسياسه اسرائيل بمحاربه وصفه بالارهابي
دون هواءته
بناء على معلومات مسبقه تفيد بالتخطيط
لهجوم كبيره ونوعيه من قبل المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين وفقا تعبيرها
قوته اعتقلت خلال ليله الماضيه مطلوبين
الفلسطينيين من انحاء ضفه الغربيه بينهم
ثلاثه يجتمعوا في ضلوعهم بتنفيذ عمليات ضد
اسرائيل
ليه وعبره حسابه حسابه على تويتر مشاهد من
عمليه اعتقالهم التي تخللتها اشتباكات نتج
عنها استشهاد اثنين من الفلسطينيين